he's got a new book out called the
quarterback whisperer how to build an
elite NFL quarterback it hits
bookshelves book stands and obviously
online stores this Wednesday he is the
head coach of the Arizona Cardinals
two-time coach of the year Bruce Arians
how are you coach Brix I'm tall great
how you doing buddy I am doing fine
so let's let's get into this why write
the book where did this come from well
you know a buddy of mine Mike such go
he's been after me like seven years to
do this book and I met Lars Andersen a
couple years ago and fitly hit it off
and they kind of told me how easy it was
and so two cocktails and a few stories
and we got a ha ha ha I was going to ask
you how many fingers deep did you get
for some of these stories code Oh many
many many double-fisted so up what may
out of all the quarterbacks that you
have whispered into the ears of and
coached Peyton Ben Roethlisberger Andrew
Luck just being 3 and obviously our
current one Carson Palmer what has been
the through line for a great NFL
quarterback well I call it grit you know
you can measure arm strength and
athletic abilities and all that stuff
and but if you don't if you can't lead
men and if you can't handle success in
failure about the same rate and real
quickly you're going to fail and how do
you Scout that how do you find that when
you're when you're looking that is the
hardest thing to scout because you
really don't know until you get up in
the huddle and it's it's one of those
things that you know you hope you find
it you listen to everybody that you talk
to and including process and evaluation
process you know you've got a pretty
good to handle on it but you don't have
the good they've led college guys but to
lead men grown men with families that's
a whole other story and how was peyton
manning when you found him I know
there's got some great stories in your
book about this in particular yeah he
was he was unbelievable you know our
veterans showed up the same time he did
and they were learning in the meetings
and he got in the first huddle dice race
get right 92 Hey be ready for cover
three and everybody like hell of it know
what that means what do you mean what
are you talking about he already had the
playbook down well and he had the
playbook down but it was a while till he
found sustainable success in the NFL and
I'm wondering if you could recount the
story that about about Peyton before a
particular Patriots game and you you
noticed some body language that that
that was disturbing to you yeah you know
he had rough outing his first time
against the Patriots and then we had
gotten we gotten better as a team the
second year and you know he was a he was
ready to go he's like one of those
horses you couldn't get in the gate and
fits it in and so I was like you get his
mind off of it and take what are you
doing with your footwork wait why are
you changing your footwork bluetongue so
just getting thinking about fundamentals
and started thinking about fundamentals
not had a great ball game and so he's a
guy that that needed some coaching up
but do you think Bruce oh I think
everybody needs coaching you know your
mom dad and God can only take you so far
and I think the relationship between a
quarterback coach and a quarterback has
to be extremely special because of the
trust level that has to be involved and
Peyton was according to your book again
a first-class prankster can you give me
that one example on your book coaching
ah they got to read the book for that
when they got to read the book for that
when that was too good okay since when
he and Kelly hey Kelly Holcomb and Steve
Walsh Billy Joe hope those guys I
thought there'd be a fight sooner or
later because the stuff they were
pulling on each other and the rest of
the team mm-hmm one of the best
practical jokers of all time okay that's
called you just you just did it like
you'd be good for TV coach that was a
tease we call it a team go read the book
Bruce Arians joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show um why is it so difficult to
fill out even 32 teams with a successful
quarterback with all of the kids that
are playing football and
all of the college programs that we're
seeing out there and the amount of of
talent in the pipeline why is it so
difficult to fill out forget sixty four
thirty two positions at quarterback yeah
it's such a hard position to play and
there are so many great college
quarterbacks that just can't handle the
volume of information and have the
mental quick twitch fibers to make
decisions at 2.5 seconds and all the
things that go into that 2.5 seconds and
you have to have arm strength you have
to have some stature but that ability to
process information quickly is the thing
that separates and how does Carson
Palmer have that Bruce Oh fantastic
fantastic I mean he's one of the
hardest-working dudes I've ever been
around so yeah we had to really pull the
reins back on him he'll overwork all the
time last year he kind of came in in
September had already worn his arm out
by overthrowing all summer and we found
a nice regiment November December he was
playing as good as he's ever played well
how much longer do you think he's going
to have at it you know I think it's
every year's going to be another
question at the end of the season how he
feels
competitively you'll never quit you know
his wife will probably have to telling
me this is it mm-hmm
and what about Larry Fitzgerald coach I
think the same the same thing you know
Sports Science which is so amazing now
these guys their bodies look like
they're 25 27 I know they're they don't
their bodies don't tell them their
mindset but with the way they train and
eat and do everything so to take care of
themselves now they can stay and play so
much longer and I used to be thirty now
I think that numbers 40 hmm well I mean
Brady certainly showing that right now
he he believes he can play deep into his
his 40s
the question is in Arizona for you and
Larry and and Carson worded you know the
whispers are um speaking of with the
coach the quarterback
whisper is the name of his book Bruce
Arians the whisper is is that the three
of you are a package deal that that you
guys look at each other and say one do
this one more year is that is there any
truth to that statement
I probably my salary was up with theirs
maybe but no that I think each of us is
totally separate and for me it's all
about health you know if I feel healthy
I'm going to coached again until I said
not I cannot do it anymore those guys I
think will have the same type of
decisions ad last year but there's no
timetable on it House David Johnson
doing Oh fantastic had a great spring
now that injury was so scary just to not
have to have surgery and to be as
full-tilt as he is right now and again
the hardest-working guys have been
around so he's ready to go he went
training camp opens he'll be there and
ready to roll oh yeah he was he was full
speed all of OTAs I think he was
actually cleared at the end of February
okay so he's ready to roll and and and
everybody's back you know you're back
and Carson well everyone on the
offensive side in a way is back
do you talk Super Bowl openly in
training camp coach always always every
every meeting that we start to season
with we setup our goals are you know we
want to win our division we want to get
to end in the playoffs but we want to
win the Super Bowl and you set those
goals and you spend you set them aside
and you start the daily process of how
to get there
and you don't talk about it anymore but
you don't shy away from it Bruce Arians
joining me for a couple more minutes
here on the Rich Eisen show the
quarterback Whisperer how to build an
elite NFL quarterback is his new book
it's on sale starting this Wednesday
he's right here on the Rich Eisen show
which is the one rule if I could wave a
wand you're now in charge of the NFL
what you as a coach would you like to do
away with
oh I think I'd blow up the CBA and start
all over
what do you mean uh especially with well
I I like I'd like to see this go back to
practicing more I think the quality of
the we have such great athletes playing
now they're kind of safe in the quality
of the game and I'd like to see the
players make more money so that's an
interesting aspect of it because from
what I remember back at the lockout
which by the way aged me like crazy I
had more hair before the lockout than
after that yeah definitely both yeah
that that that was kind of a trade-off
that the players for concessions that
the owners got they got the time off how
do you think it is affecting play in the
NFL all that time off well I go back to
last year I think offense and defensive
lineman were in patch for 11 days before
we played a game a preseason game and
it's just not enough and people worry
about injuries what you can't teach them
how to play football
all right we're not playing soccer it's
okay for wide receivers and DBS run
around in shorts but the linebackers
running backs the tight ends and
defensive line like they got out they
could have some contact it doesn't have
to be head-on contact
everybody's worried about more head
injuries it just has to be blocking and
tackling that proper way more often say
it one more time coach I didn't just
better practice you know more you don't
have people always worry about more
concussions if you practice longer and
if you're doing things properly they're
avoided so when it all comes down to it
coach
you know writing a book or coaching a
national football league team I mean
when it all comes down to it how much
more help do you get for something like
that writing a book or coaching a game
uh-huh coaching the game they do we got
a great staff we had a great staff and
it you couldn't do it without them bless
with I
most eclectic different staff we know we
are Tom Friday t2 Tom or 80 right and
some guys 26 27 a couple former players
young guys and so it's such a great
staff that way well when you come out
Los Angeles way I really would love
having in studio and really dig into
stories like you're telling in your book
you know obviously involve it with Paul
Bear Bryant and and and and other couple
of coaches Jim Moore a senior I mean
you've just been around some some great
characters and some greats coach and I'd
love to pick your brain some more before
the season I love to do a rich quick
good you got it that's Bruce Arians
Arizona Cardinals head coach here on the
Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like some of that get some more
of that on the Rich Eisen show lap
follow all the information you see right
here on the Rich Eisen show